hi there I'm Anna Prosser Robinson for
gamespot on the front line at San Diego
comic-con 2014 I'm standing here with
someone who you may recognize as her
video has been all over the internet and
rightfully so it's so impressive
I'm here with Kacy Catanzaro are you
doing today I'm doing great how are you
I'm doing wonderful I actually just did
the Assassin's Creed unity obstacle
course just a little while ago and I
heard you're gonna do it too
you've already done it I'm jealous yeah
I've just gotten kind of a sneak peak on
it but I haven't gotten to see all of
the obstacles yet I'm actually very glad
that I did it before you so that I
didn't have to follow your performance
cuz I'm assuming considering what I know
you can already do this this might be a
piece of cake for you what do you think
I think it's gonna be pretty fun there's
gonna be those challenges but it's gonna
be awesome
have you looked at the course at all yet
I've gotten some sneak peeks but I
haven't gotten to see like each obstacle
and think about what to do yet
well Shidoshi told me that I have the
best time so far I don't know if he was
lying to make me feel good but he said I
did it in like one minute 20 seconds I
don't know I could be wrong but do you
think you can be fat that sounds pretty
fast but I think I can top it well we'll
see I guess
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Casey I'm catching you before you fully
have time to catch your breath how are
you feeling great definitely winded but
it was so much fun
what was the best or most fun obstacle I
think that this big spinning thing was
really fun you know because it's at the
end so you're tired but you're so close
you could see the buzzer so you just
want to zoom through it I I heard that
you did beat my time I guess it was not
my very much thank you for saying that I
appreciate it if I if I anyone's gonna
beat my time I'm glad it was you it's
been absolutely a pleasure to meet you
thank you so much thank you guys so much
for having me hey guys um where can
where can people tweet at you just at
kacy catanzaro and you can also tweet at
me tell me how jealous of me you are
that I got to meet Casey at Anna Prosser